Oh
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Torchwood I've touched on a few times
people asked me if I am ever gonna do
episode by observed reviews or more top
10s of often Torchwood and I've always
said probably not because to do so would
involve doing a full rewatch because
I've watched any of Torchwood in years
and my feelings about the show or so on
even that I don't really want to do that
but there's always been one exception
I've I've always had but had a tendency
to be like well you know what maybe I'll
revisit children of Earth one of these
days I had no idea when I was going to
get to it but one of my patreon
supporters decided they were tired of
waiting and commissioned me to to get to
it so children of Earth I have not
watched this in probably not quite a
decade but close like I watched this
when it aired and I haven't read watched
it since not because I didn't like it I
I had thought it was actually great and
it's by far the most solid season of
Torchwood that I've seen I said was a
miracle day but I heard that was uneven
aside too so this this feels like an
anomaly and Torchwood in a lot of ways
but it I was both excited in and kind of
terrified to revisit this not terrified
than like oh my god will it still be
good way but last time I saw this thing
I wasn't a parent yet I didn't have my
own kid I do now and yeah this this this
was hard this may very well be the
darkest thing ever done in a Doctor Who
universe story with the exception of
maybe the sky man over at Big Finish but
this is bleak and even if I were to
compare this on my sky man or even if I
compared to something like black mirror
those things are an hour this is five
episodes nearly an hour piece this is a
lot and it starts bleak and it gets
worse and worse and here's the thing
it's not bleak because oh it's it's a
little bit tragic and you know spoilers
not everything turns out well but it's
bleak because the way people respond and
react to the situation that they're in
feels incredibly real it really puts you
in a position of asking yourself what
would I do
how would I feel and I think it's very
hard to not empathize with but a lot of
the characters with what's going on here
so in case folks aren't familiar with
children or birth here is our starting
premise there is a day where every
single child on the planet just stops
like totally frozen in motion doesn't
last long as few seconds then they go
about the day as like well that was
weird huh and most people don't make the
connection that this happened literally
everywhere on the planet at the exact
same moment in time Torchwood catches on
because that's their thing uh and then
the children stop again they all speak
they all speaking uniform in unison and
they say we are coming and that heralds
the coming
of an alien species known only as the
four five six that is all we know of
them in terms of their background their
history much of anything and it is
learned that they have a interest in the
children of Earth they also have the
capabilities of wiping us out if we
don't do what they want and it goes from
there and I will be getting into
spoilers and I will say before I get
there but it's not enough for just to
endanger a child when I say not enough
like for me that's kind of enough I've
said before that's a bit of a hot button
for me like even before I was a parent
it's not something I'm particularly
comfortable watching but it's not enough
for this show to just endanger kids it
actually makes the other characters and
the audience know sir and they sent also
afraid of the children as much as they
are afraid for them because these
children are the mouthpiece for a big
chunk of this thing of this alien
species and you see parents even some
who kinda have an idea of what's going
on and the vast majority of people don't
like a few who do freaking out and
terrified you know shouting at their
children stop and of course baby don't
they're not in control of their own
voices
and of course that's an inherently
creepy thing all these children just
frozen locked in just speaking with a
slightly modulated voice yeah you can
still hear the youth in their own voice
behind that a big part of what makes
this bleak really is just how much more
relevant it feels now
and if if if this sort of thing is
difficult for you to watch I would
approach this with caution it is very
well done but it's very hard to get
through and I I don't recommend binging
it space out the episodes take breathers
because I am gonna start getting into
spoilers to talk about some of the stuff
that I really need to talk about here it
is unsettling both now as a parent
myself but also in light of how suddenly
topical it feels to see images of
soldiers pulling screaming children away
from their parents that's the kind of
imagery we're dealing with in in the
fifth episode in the last episode and
part of the brilliance of this thing is
it builds to that so the children are
endangered pretty much throughout this
entire thing but we start with almost a
prologue sequence to 1965 where 12
children were handed over to the 456
they were basically taken to a field
told to walk into a light and then they
were gone and that in and of itself is
hard to watch but there is escalation
because at that point and also for the
first sort of chunks of things you know
children being put on buses or whatnot
the children have a certain trustiest
there they're not sure what's going on
they're uneasy but they're like these
are the adults they're gonna they're
listening I said okay okay well guess
we'll do that and they don't know what's
coming the adults do but the kids don't
and then towards the end where what the
people in authority the people in power
decide that they're going to do
in order to placate the four-five-six
basically give them 10% of the child
population of the planet and that's what
the four five six wants and that's what
they're gonna give them and the lengths
that they're prepared to go to escalates
to pulling screaming children away from
parents and it's unsettling to be able
to turn on the news and see very very
similar footage and I don't wanna I
don't want to turn this into a big
political point but like that that was
part of the reality of miry watching
this so there you go we get a really big
highlight on Peter Capaldi as a
character by the name of John Frobisher
who's just a government middleman he's
just the guy who comes in and puts in
the work and tries to keep they trying
it and tries to grease the wheels you
can keep everything moving smoothly he
gets a lot of stuff dumped on him
and he nods and he does the work for
people who are making decisions above
his pay grade but are also prepared to
leave him holding the bag when it and
when it comes time for consequences to
happen and Capaldi's great in this you
really get the sense of conflict because
he is a parent which means his children
are at stake with what's going on and
his commitment to seeing this job
through he believes that his job has
value even as he's being asked to do
these things until he's pushed the point
that he is at the very end where he's
told that his children will be given up
to the four five six so that it
maintains the image that the government
was
by them and didn't and didn't do this
voluntarily it has to look like the the
people in government also suffered a
loss because otherwise if all their
children are protected it's too obvious
and that pushes them to the point that
he kills his children and his wife and
himself and it's a character that could
have been very slimy
very spineless and very unsympathetic
and he's none of those things and he's
not just sympathetic for the easy link
of he's a parent with his own kids he's
sympathetic because Peter Capaldi
injects a lot of empathy into this
character the 456 it's great that we see
so little of them we see these sort of
they almost look like scorpion tails
like in this mist and like when they
talk and communicate they're like spew
this this green it's like bile but it
just seems to be something that they do
but we never get a good look at them
which is I think to the to the benefits
mostly just the voice that we get and
this is also one of those instances
where finding out some of the answers
makes the situation scarier and more
depressing more effective because I
remember watching this the first time
and obviously this time I already knew
but I remember watching this for the
first time and thinking to myself what
possible use could they have for the
children you know what whatever the
answer this is it's gonna be
disappointment but wasn't because the
idea that they are getting high off some
thing that human children do or
generator emanate or whatever they're
putting
us and like we are here turning over our
children for something so stupid and
Hollow and empty that's that's I think
that's part of why it's because like dr.
who has done children being used by
aliens before school reunion leaves mine
but they're you know children were being
used but for a purpose a grand purpose
but not you know one the doctor to stop
up for a purpose here like there's no
purpose it's just for the high that
makes it even bleaker there are a couple
of stumbling blocks in this thing and
unfortunately they actually have to do
with Torchwood itself as a as an entity
because honestly for what's the most
effective stuff about the narrative they
don't need to be they're the most
effective stuff deals with frobisher
deals with the families torn apart deals
with how the government responds both
those who choose to shut down all their
emotions and look at this is just a cold
calculation and just make sure that they
cover their own butts which is another
thing that feels really true like in the
middle of this crisis aliens have come
for our children that there are still
people whose first concern is I can't
let this make me look bad and all that
is the most effective stuff in the film
and the in the miniseries and that's not
to say Torchwood is not effective at all
but that story could have happened
without them and been just as effective
as it was this really kind of comes to a
head and actually only the second
episode because the second episode
honestly is pointless as far as the
greater story goes because the entire
second episode it is Torchwood you know
having you know some members running
Jack having been captured but nothing
about the actual plot moves forward it
just spins its wheels with torch
would actually seems and Gwen Cooper
firing her gun like this and it's the
it's the weakest episode by a country
mile and it's the one that focuses on
focuses is almost entirely on the team
and again I don't I don't want in in you
know the I do like these characters I
like Jack I like Ianto I like when I
like Rhys I like Andy but I'm only happy
to see them because I already have an
interest in them if I was watching this
for the first time and didn't already
know them I would kind of be annoyed
that the really incredibly intense and
compelling stories being diverted so
that we can spend time with these
characters that don't really seem to be
helping the situation really and you
know Ianto is death handled fairly well
III wondered if it was gonna choke me
out more this time it didn't I think
maybe it's just I didn't quite have the
level of affection for Ianto that a lot
of fans of Torchwood do I like Ianto I
missed and I'm sorry he died but I guess
I I wasn't as invested in him as a
character I didn't really I wasn't super
impacted when Owen and Tosh died either
just for the record but boy I gotta
explain this one carefully the death of
Jack's grandson doesn't quite work not
as well as it should for one reason that
may not have been something that the
makers could control and for another
reason that they could so the thing that
they couldn't control is that the the
mother doesn't sell the grief completely
you know I if I were to compare it to
say the there was the reaction of the
father of Cedric Diggory in the fourth
Harry Potter like that is Myles
or Trajan you feel the pain and I don't
know if it's that they're lingering the
shots too long and she wasn't sure what
to do but she doesn't sell the grief
hard enough jack does actually he sell
his performance is pretty much pitch
perfect but that's not enough because we
don't know this kid well enough the show
could have done more to really ring that
but it seems to just assume that it's
the offspring of a character we like
it's a kid who dies that's enough but we
see very little of this kid he interacts
with Jack almost not at all we don't
even see him interact with his mother
all that much and like said she
unfortunate doesn't doesn't sell it
particularly hard either so for this to
work for this to be the true emotional
climax and for this to be the gut punch
that I think it's supposed to be one of
the I'm what they really needed to do
was give us they needed to characterize
the kid because he's just a kid he's not
a proper character we don't know
anything about him we don't know what he
likes we don't know what kind of
relationship he has with his mother or
with Jack I mean we know jack is a
little estranged from him but we're not
invested in him as a character we're
invested in him as a prop
basically so and if they weren't gonna
do that I mean my recommendation would
have been to basically scrap almost all
of us though too and like instead put it
in stuff like this so this lands
properly but if you're not gonna do that
my backup suggestion would have
to not have it end with the death of
Jack's grandson but instead with Clem so
Clem is the adult who was the one child
from 1965 who got away but he's still
connected and he's very unstable and
he's very afraid now we spend time with
him we get to know him we see that he's
a kind-hearted but very unsettled person
and I think and I'm not even saying that
this would have been the best way to go
but given that I don't feel that the
kids death hits as hard as the show
wants to do I think it actually would
have hit harder if Clem had been the
connection to the 456 that they did but
to not have him do this willingly still
have Jack do what he does which is to
make a decision that is going to kill
someone who is not volunteering and who
probably doesn't even fully understand
what's going on and have him realize
your pain like you could have milked
that because we know him we know him a
heck of a lot more than we know the
grandson and like I say that would be
better but I only mean that would be
better than what happened but it still
is really what they should have done
what they really should have done was
properly and fully characterized the
grandson and I didn't that only kind of
that that doesn't even really render it
ineffective just sort of complained of
it it's so weird to me that I complain
that this thing isn't bleak enough oh
god what is wrong with me
but I'm not this is not a case of the
ending drops the ball it doesn't drop
the ball but it should hit harder than
it does and that's sort of my thing it's
not a bad or ineffectual ending it just
could have been more brutal
than it is and because as it stands the
shows most brutal episodes I would say
are one in three at least as far as the
endangerment of the kids go
if Ianto is the hardest moment for you
then for you be episode four
I I don't like episode five could have
been the true emotional just drop a rock
on you but it's not it's still really
good the performances aside from a
couple of little nitpicks
are good the guest cast is good
Lois's the character of Lois is good
the Prime Minister is you will come to
loathe him by the time this thing is
done and he earns that without being
overly arch and like maniacal just very
very much a self-preserving politician
and again that's part of what feels very
real about this and the thing is again I
think going to how bleak and dark this
thing is the Prime Minister effectively
gets deposed at the end or it's been
said it's setup that he is gonna answer
for decisions he made to sacrifice
children and try and hide the fact that
he was doing that but that and there's
some catharsis in that but it's not
really treated like a proper trying
because if you're paying attention the
woman who is positioning herself to take
over
she was the same one who said that they
should not choose which children go by
any kind of random lottery but instead
pick the bad children yeah if she's
gonna take over that's not much better
there's still some catharsis in seeing
green the prime-minister go down but if
you pay attention this is not actually
an improvement and again this thing is
dark this seems this has a very very
bleak view of I'm not gonna say humanity
as a whole but certainly of the people
in power and the people who are carrying
out their orders it has an incredibly
bleak view of them and it's one that I
wish didn't feel more relevant now than
it did when it aired and ultimately I
think that maybe the point that this
thing is making more than anything else
as much as their shock value and
endangering and harming or killing
children that's not the point of what
this thing is and what I love but in
this sills easily stands - the best
thing towards whatever did and the thing
is this because this is mature in the
way that I wanted
Torchwood to be mature this is mature
because it is dark and bleak and heavy
subject matter and really forces you to
ask questions about yourself and and
what would you do you know where would
you draw the line who who is willing to
truly sacrifice to save everyone else
Jack was could you I couldn't it makes
you ask those questions and that is the
kind of mature I wanted Torchwood as
opposed to the kind of mature that it
often was prior to this which was mature
because
oh they they said the f-word it's mature
because oh look they're banging that's
not mature that's sophomoric that's I
mean that's juvenile it's what has been
labeled by society as mature content but
it's incredibly juvenile this is true
proper mature storytelling it's it's got
its issues it's got its nitpicks it I I
I remember it episode two being a bit of
dead weight and I'd hoped I would find
more value in it this time I really like
you could you can practically skip it
you know the the previously on and the
start of episode three tells you enough
that you can pretty much skip it and
again it's not even bad it just is
completely unnecessary but what is here
that works is so good and so dark and so
shaking yeah I I can't help but take my
hat here here we go we'll do it I can't
help but I actually take my hat off to
this thing because oh and with this over
and behind me I got a I don't know
I got a you know what I'm gonna you know
we're gonna do I'm gonna see if my
daughter is up for rewatching Hilda yes
that's that's what I could use right now
Torchwood children of Earth you've seen
it what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it
like and subscribe they both help
there's also a patreon helps me cover my
bills and also grow the channel plus
links to other things below they're all
down below check them out click on them
or don't I'm not gonna tell you what to
do folks cuz I'm not gonna make
decisions behind your back about what's
best for you and then have some
subordinate carryout
against their own inch
because you're the council and I'm just
running them he thinks that God
elaborate so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]